It's much easier now to gain fame.
But it's harder to last.
You know, I want to be famous
like the Kardashians
who are famous for just being famous.
Fame, in its earliest forms,
is some sense that
human beings need
something beyond themselves.
So they almost invented gods as a way
of explaining what happened next.
And, if there are gods, there's going
to be contact with gods.
Some people are going to be
closer to them than others.
The word celebrity itself
in the 1400s
still meant the celebration
of the sacred.
The period where
the nature of fame changed
from people attributing
god-like qualities to it
was when Charles I was executed.
Something big had changed.
And part of that is
the sense of self-making
that becomes prominent
at this period.
The idea that you
don't have to be rich,
you do not have to be an
aristocrat to be a person of fame.
We begin to enter into a situation
where the people become celebrities.
He represents the cult of
personality that we now know today.
Oscar really was a nascent celebrity.
His philosophy of life was that the
point of life is self-realisation,
just as the point of art
is self-expression.
You have to bring
out what it is inside you.
The famous people in the 1880s
were politicians, scientists,
doctors, writers.
By 1920, it was
singers, sportsmen, actors.
And the reason for that
is the invention of film,
which gives you the illusion of being
in touch with somebody
and close to them and forming bonds
with them, without ever meeting them.
Warhol was at the time, in the 60s,
creating this real buzz around him,
and creating this iconic figure
that people flocked to.
And he certainly influenced the people
and the scene around New York City.
And you could think about that today
with people who really
influence the social scene today -
whether it might be somebody
like Kim Kardashian,
and the followers that she has, who
want to look like her physically.
There's a draw to
wanting to be that figure,
wanting to be that famous.
Think about Warhol right now in this
era that we live in
with everybody taking selfies and
these images of themselves,
and thinking back to Warhol when he
filmed himself eating a hamburger.
I mean, he was one of the pioneers
of turning the camera on oneself.
Think about Andy Warhol now
with an iPhone.
That would be the best
Instagram account to follow, right?
Why so many people
are attracted to celebrities
is that we live in an age
of profound anxiety.
Part of that is wanting
acceptance and approval in life.
You want to be accepted by people,
and you want to be
approved by people.
Who are the people that have paid most
to be accepted and approved?
Celebrities.
Some people document their life,
which means that they don't lie -
they just have a camera rolling.
And some people create their life,
so they actually stage a picture.
They actually stage an outfit.
I think that this will be
the difference between
a good influencer
and a bad influencer.
You have to be real,
because people will feel that
whatever you're telling them to do,
if it's not real and if it doesn't
come from your heart
and whatever you believe in,
they know.
I strongly believe that
the more you go into
the pieces of you that
most people would hide,
the better of an influencer
you are going to be.
The more you're sharing things
that people are like,
"What? I'm that way too."
That's when people get excited.
That's when they want to follow you.
And it could just be that this
smaller kind of fame -
this idea of finding
your niche or your tribe -
people may come
more and more to value
smaller, individual acts of kindness
and of love,
and become celebrated for them.